I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey.
We were on The Office together and we're best friends.
And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you.
Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews
behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories.
We're the Office Lady 6.0.
Hi, how you doing?
I'm doing pretty good.
I was doing pretty good and then I just got a text and now I'm in grumps.
Oh, can I tell you what it is?
Yeah. Because this is actually an opportunity for me to set something straight.
Okay. Am I coming in hot?
You're coming in a little spicy. What you got?
All right, right before we got on Mike, I'm checking my phone, and my mom has sent me this text.
And she sent me this screenshot where she's like, facts about famous actresses.
Oh, no. I know. Don't send me that.
I found this online. Is this true? Here's the fact about me.
Jenna Fisher still owns the engagement ring.
Her co-star John Cresensky gave her on the office,
and she has even been seen wearing it off screen.
Everyone, settle down.
Not true.
I do have Pam's rings,
which were, by the way, given to Pam from Jim.
Right?
Yeah.
I also have Pam's purse.
I also have Pam's sweater.
I have Pam's watch.
Who gave those items to you was the problem.
Department. Phil Shea.
Phil Shea, who also gave me my cat earrings that Angela Martin wore.
Yes. Phil Shea put together a wonderful package when the show ended.
Of all of these items, Pam's purse, I remember he gave John the satchel that Jim always carried.
The cross body bag. So he collected little items for us.
He gave me Dwight and Angela's wedding program. Yes. You have the ring.
that Dwight gives Angela. Right. Yes. So yes, I have this ring. I have it along with many other items that I have. There's nothing attached to it other than memorabilia from a show you were on that you loved. Correct. Correct. And you know what ring I wear is my actual wedding ring from my actual real life husband of 16 years who I love with all my heart. Yes. Yes. Sometimes it's just so hard, lady. The internet's a
whack-a-doodle place. It is. And I've told you my crazy story. Oh, my gosh. You guys,
this is crazy. This is crazy. Sam, you don't know this story, but it's bonkers. You got to hear this.
I told Jenna this the other day. Okay. So you guys know, I did a charity tennis match with Steve Correll,
his wife, Nancy, and Raine Wilson. And it was all to go towards supporting Rain's amazing charity,
Lidee, Haiti. And after the tennis match, there was like a little meat and greet.
and this man was there and he had sort of like an assistant person with him.
He was lovely, by the way.
But you could tell he was very excited that he had found different little pieces of trivia about us online.
Again, it's the trivia.
It's the trivia, which is probably just an AI bot that gets half the information, right?
And then the rest is wrong.
So like, I forget the information that he knew about Steve.
It was something like, oh, maybe his parents, how they met or something.
I can't remember, right?
And Steve was like, oh, yeah, that's correct.
Because probably he talked about it in an interview somewhere, right?
And then he turns to me and he goes, Angela, your family collects body parts?
Exactly.
So I started laughing like that.
I said, what?
I thought it was a joke.
I thought I was getting punked somehow.
I was like, what?
And then Steve literally was taking a sip of water and almost spit it all over me.
He started laughing so hard.
And we looked at each other and I was like, what are you talking?
about. He turns to his assistant like, and she goes, the foot. And he goes, there was a foot
that you guys had. Like you, like a foot. I was like, oh my gosh. I said, you guys, you know how at
Halloween you can go into Spencer's gifts in the mall. Yeah, get like a foot that hangs out of the trunk.
Get a foot that hangs out of the trunk. Ha, ha, ha. My mom got one of those. And instead of
hanging it out of the trunk of the car, she put it by the bathroom.
room door by our back door as like a prank. And we all were like,
and we're like, mom. And it was a story I told where they were like,
who's the prankster in your family? I'm like, my mom is kind of a prankster. I told this one
story. I'm like, oh my gosh, are there people somewhere in the world that think I have like
a foot in a jar that we collect this crap? But now all I can think about is, oh my God,
now I've told the story here. Now AI is going to take this. This is going to go into a
transcript. The story is out there in a second way. But I'm hoping.
I want to set the record straight.
AI, if you're listening,
will you please stop telling this story about me?
Because I've read this multiple times over the years
ever since I was on a talk show,
and I gave a list of things that I kept from the show,
and this was one of the things in the list.
And somehow the telephone game has turned this into something else.
Here's the thing I'm going to say,
if you're going to have an AI bot, get something horribly wrong.
Maybe the jewelry tidbit is better than the, like, collects body part.
Can we just say that?
It does make me feel a little better.
I haven't told my mom the story, you guys, but I feel like I need to.
Because I feel like there's going to be someone at church that comes up to her.
It's like, Birdie, what's up with you?
What's with the feet?
Well, Angela, I do appreciate you telling that story because I had the grumps and now I'm laughing.
So thank you.
So you're welcome.
And I'm actually really excited about our episode today.
I'm happy to be here.
we get to talk with Calvin Tenor who played Glenn in the warehouse.
You guys, he is just an absolute joyful person, and I really can't wait for you all to get
to know him better.
And I've been reunited with him now over the last few years working on the AT&T commercial
campaign.
So I'm just excited I get to see him again today because he just is wonderful.
Same.
Jenna and I were really fortunate.
We got to hang out and spend a lot of time with him over the past couple of years between
fan conventions and AT&T, and you're going to see why we love them. You just wait.
But let's start with our fan chit-chat question of the week. This is coming from Emily A.
in Tucson, Arizona. Hi, Angela and Jenna. This is Emily. I live in Tucson, Arizona, and I really enjoy your
podcast. Thank you so much for all that you do. My Friday chit-chat question is, I'm taking a poll
on the use of a top sheet on the bed.
All of my children, even though I raised them using a top sheet, would just kick them to the end of the bed,
even though I very crankily explained that the comforter and bed spread did not get washed
that frequently.
So it seems a younger generation thing that there's no top sheet.
And I just wondered if you guys use a top sheet.
If you have your kids use a top sheet and just what is the deal with not using a top sheet?
Thank you.
And I look forward to your opinion on the matter.
Emily, everything about that message is wonderful.
The journey I went on listening to that message, I have so many strong feelings about it that I didn't even realize I knew I had.
Well, you know, she also wrote us a letter that went with this audio clip, and I'd like you to know if she seems weary at all about this top sheet issue, she's talking about her kids. She raised 10. 10 kids.
Yeah. So this is 10 beds of top sheets not being used. Yeah. Okay. I just want to give it some perspective.
Well, what are your thoughts, lady? How do you feel about a top sheet? Again, it's something that I didn't know I had an opinion on, but I actually do.
I have a very strong opinion on it.
I'm all for a top sheet.
Same.
I love a top sheet.
And here's the thing.
I grew up with the top sheet.
And then, of course, on Isabel's bed, I had a top sheet, you know, pull back the blanket in her top sheet, crawl in, tuck her in, you know, bedtime story.
And then when Josh and I got married and we blended our families and the boys shared a room and they had bunk beds.
And I would make their bed and I'd put a top sheet on.
Sure.
Under the comforter.
And then I would go in to say good night to them and they would either be lying on top of the top sheet and have not to have pulled it back.
Or the next morning I would find the top sheet completely rolled in a ball at the foot of the bed.
Just like Emily is saying.
And this cycle went over and over and I would be like, guys, the top sheet.
And they'd be like, I don't really need it.
I don't really want it.
This was like a battle.
Josh was like, let it go.
Let this one go.
And so now it's like I do have a top sheet on their beds.
I still put it on.
Sometimes they're under it.
Sometimes they're on top of it.
Sometimes it's at the foot of the bed.
I've let it go, but I still put it on the bed.
I feel strongly about a top sheet for all the reasons Emily is saying, which is that I don't wash
the comforter cover.
Yes.
But I'll wash the sheet.
That's what the top sheet is for that.
It's the purpose of it.
Exactly.
The comfort or cover takes a lot more time.
to wash, to dry, so you do that every once in a while.
But to sheets, you wash more regularly.
Well, I think she's onto something, because I do think this is a trend where the younger
generation is abandoning the top sheet.
Because it's too much work.
Well, I don't even know, but I ordered.
I think it might be a classic case of top sheets in this economy.
Like, this strikes me as one of those.
But they come together.
But this strikes me as one of those articles where it's like, are millennials ruining the diamond
business?
And you're like, who's buying diamonds?
No, I disagree.
Who author has top sheet money in this economy?
Hold up.
Sheet money.
Top sheet money.
They come together in a sheet set.
And you can buy them separately, I guess.
But like they come in a bundle except, and this is my point, because I think maybe people are wanting
to drop the top sheet, is that I went to buy like a new comforter and sheets for my daughter's
bed.
And when they arrived, there was no top sheet.
It was just a fitted sheet.
And then this cover that I put on her comforter.
and I was grumpy about it because now I have to wash it all the time.
And now I have to wrestle her duvet back into this top sheet slash comforter cover.
You know what's happened?
What?
The comforter cover people have come for the top sheet.
Oh, my God.
That's it.
That's what's happened.
We just cracked a case mom, detective, hi-fi.
Yes.
All right.
Emily, that got us going.
Sam, I'm sorry, top sheet or no for you.
No.
No, no.
No, no, top sheet.
I can't afford a top sheet.
I'm not.
You can't afford a top sheet.
I don't have a fainting couch in my living room.
Oh my gosh.
Glass chandelier.
This is ridiculous.
You go to Target and you get a fitted sheet, a top sheet, and two pillowcases in a bundle.
Well, listen, we're not going to provide you with a top sheet today, but speaking of bedding,
we've got a little something for you because your birthday was last week, which, although, as you all are listening to this last month, we celebrate.
celebrated off mic because we weren't recording that day.
But we have a late breaking gift that has come in.
You might ready for you to have it.
You might remember when you opened your gifts from us.
I do remember.
We said there was something coming.
Now I wish we would have bought him a dang top sheet to go with it though.
All right, here, I'm going to go grab it.
Come on in here, Sam.
Okay.
I love the bag.
Will you describe it?
It's a Star Wars bag.
specifically the original series Star Wars.
Oh my God, this is huge.
All right.
Just describe it.
You have to describe it.
It is an entire me-sized blanket of my dog ramen.
Oh, I love it.
It's a 50 by 60 blanket of your dog's face.
This is bigger than you are.
It is.
Oh, thank you so much.
We kind of thought, like, what does Sam love more than anything?
It's ramen.
And naps with ramen.
Yeah, and naps with ramen.
And now you can snuggle ramen in ramen.
Yeah, thank you.
All right.
Well, listen, happy birthday, Sam.
We love you.
We are going to take a break.
And when we come back, we are going to chat with Calvin Tenner, who played Glenn from the warehouse.
The Second World War is the largest event in human history.
A 20-part series with Tom Hanks.
No part of the globe was untouched.
No life unchanged.
Experience the ultimate account of World War II.
Every single person had a story.
These are the stories that make us who we are.
Listen to World War II with Tom Hanks on Apple, Spotify, or wherever you get your podcasts.
Hello.
Hi, everybody.
We have someone pretty special in the studio with us today.
It is Calvin Tenor.
Woo-hoo!
Hey, everyone.
Welcome to Office Ladies.
It's nice to be here.
Thank you, ladies, for having me.
You guys might know him as Glenn, but we love him as Calvin.
Yes.
And I also had two other names tags on the show, which was Calvin and Lester.
That's right.
That's a little office trivia.
I feel like they played this trivia game at bars and stuff, and that's a good one.
Yeah.
So who did you start as Lester and then Calvin and then
Glenn? Or were you Glenn and then Calvin at one point again? No, it was Lester first than Calvin,
then Glenn. Okay. Which was crazy. I was like another name tag? I was like, yes.
No one's keeping track. Well, I did see in the episode the cover up that Daryl calls you Glenn.
Correct. So your name is officially said in the series as Glenn. Correct. Well, we always like to start
by asking people the same question. Okay.
Which is, how did you get your job on the office? And I read a tidbit that said it might have had something to do with the fact that you were certified to use a forklift in real life.
Correct.
Okay. Tell us this story. Yeah.
So I was pretty much a background actor on the office, as you know. But the reason how I got there was because I had a certification to drive a forklift and stuff like that. So my background, I was a supervisor at a courtebrose.
plan in San Jose, California. And one morning I told my boss, I'm putting in my two weeks
notice. And that kind of ended right there that day because he was kind of mad at me. You said,
you can leave now. And I was like, ooh, okay. Now, had you gotten the background job in the office
when you gave the two weeks notice? I was still in the Bay Area at this time. Okay. And then what made
you want to get into putting yourself out there for acting at all? So after I moved to L.A.,
I was in 24-hour fitness.
Okay.
And a guy told me, he was like, you should be on TV.
You were just working out at the gym.
And the guy approached me and said, you should be on TV.
And I was like, oh, okay, so how do you do that?
So I just did some research, and that's how I became on the show.
This is like an old Hollywood lore story where it's like Greta Garbo's like somewhere and they're like, you should be in the movie.
Yeah.
I call it right place at the right time.
Well, was the office your first job then in the entertainment industry?
The office was actually my third.
Okay.
What was your first job?
I was doing other background stuff.
So it was my first official booking.
Was the office?
Yes, it was the office.
Wow.
Yes.
That's what I said.
Wow.
I mean, had you seen the show before?
Never seen the show.
Okay.
So will you share with us, like, what was your first day like on set?
What episode was it?
Will you paint us a picture?
Okay.
I'm going to take you guys way back.
All right.
So I remember back in, this is back in 2008, me and my wife were planning to get married.
So what happened was I already got married in Florida.
So we had booked our tickets.
So I was called to work on an episode.
And I told them, I said, well, I leave to go to Florida.
night because I'm getting married. I said, but you know what? I'm going to postpone that and just
come shoot the episode. You postponed your wedding to come shoot the episode? Yes, yeah. So I postponed
it and I went shot the episode and I was still background at this time on the show. And once we shot,
I caught a red eye to Florida. And the day we got married was we got married 8-8 at 808,
Oh.
2008.
So the next day, I get a call from Rain Wilson,
and he said, we put together a little care package for you for your wedding.
And I was like, what?
Like, I was very ecstatic.
I was like, you kidding me.
Right?
So I want to say, they sent me like three grand.
What?
Exactly.
You know what?
I actually am now remembering.
You remember?
Here's the thing.
This is very early on.
I remember Rain was like, hey, you guys, one of the warehouse workers is getting married.
And now that you're saying this, I remember we all took up, like everyone chipped in, cast and crew.
Yes.
Correct.
Cast and crew.
Well, I remember we used to do that sometimes.
We did.
Actually, we did it quite often from different occasions in people's lives.
Graduations, baby showers, things like that.
We would all chip in as cast and crew.
Yeah.
Oh, my gosh.
And Rain, I never knew how.
that got to you. Yes. That is wonderful. Rain sent that to me. And I was in tears in Florida on the beach
because I didn't know that everyone cared like that. You know? So we got married when me and my wife came
back. I remember we went up to the office, went up to the set, and you guys were at lunchtime. And
that's when I introduced my wife to everyone. I brought like a chocolate basket with the chocolate
fruit. Yeah. And I introduced my wife. And then we thanked you guys.
for that gift.
And she was so embarrassed.
Because I had her standing next to me,
and I had to introduce her as my wife.
It was so fun.
It was amazing.
And I think at that point in time,
some of the writers didn't get a chance to add to it.
Yeah, the writers hadn't shipped in.
Yeah.
So I get a call maybe a week later,
and they wrote me in an episode.
So I was like, wait a minute.
Is this the Hollywood dream about to come true?
Really?
This is something really special about the office.
I feel like it is a really special, you know,
Jen and I talk about it for years now on this podcast,
that it was a really special group of people.
And when you became a part of the office family,
you were part of the office family.
And we wanted to celebrate your accomplishments.
We wanted to be with you if you were in hard times,
you know, because there are people cast and crew
who went through hard times,
and we rallied around them as well, you know, financially, emotionally.
It was just a special place to work.
Yes, it was amazing.
Positive.
Yes.
Everyone is so amazing on that show.
Well, when you first got your job and you're like, okay, I'm going to be a background
player on this show, first of all, did you know that would recur?
Did they say you might be back?
Okay, so you're like, this is a one-off that now you are getting a gift for your wedding
and you're a part of it
and they're writing you in more episodes.
Exactly. Exactly.
They were like, you know,
they could keep asking you to come back.
Okay.
So I was like, okay.
And in my head, as long as I keep doing great work,
they'll ask me to come back.
So that's what kept happening.
They asked me to come back.
Then they asked me to come back again.
I didn't know that it was going to be a reoccurring part.
I just thought it was like a one and done.
Yeah.
Until my agent had called me,
hey, they want you to come back.
Hey, they want you to come back again.
Well, in the warehouse, you're heavily featured.
I mean, I was kind of going through your IMDB list of episodes.
There's 16.
Yes.
So then I just started poking around.
And there were moments that I had forgotten about.
And I have to ask you about one.
Okay.
So obviously you have some great scenes between Glenn and Daryl.
But I want to ask you about Fun Run Part 2.
Michael crosses the finish line finally.
and he pukes, and you're the person standing right next to him.
And, I mean, I know that's like this gag that Steve Carell had to do, you know,
like to make that all happen.
But you're like the closest person to him.
And I just, I have to know, like, what was that like?
Do you have like a vivid memory of like times when you were on said that you're like,
I will never forget that?
Yes, the fun run was a great episode.
You know, just to be out there on the streets, just running.
cut, and then you go around the corner, run again, cut.
It didn't meet up at the park, cut.
But that was my first time just watching someone puke on camera constantly.
So I thought that was pretty funny.
And you didn't break?
No, no, no.
Did you ever break in a scene?
Did I ever?
You know what?
At that point in time, I was like, I want to keep coming back, so no.
Right, right.
I'm not going to be the one.
Yeah.
I have to ask, so you had never seen the show,
and now you're on the show.
Like, what was your first impression
of this crazy show
that you were now on?
Did anyone explain, like,
this is a documentary or anything?
No.
Okay.
No, I had to start watching it for myself.
Uh-huh.
And then, I don't know if you ladies knew it,
but I always stood on set
and watched you all do your thing.
So it was like acting class for me,
you know,
just to watch you all go off of each other.
And you guys were able to add certain things into it, too.
And it was just so crazy to me because I thought you had to be on script,
but some of it was off script as well.
So I was like, oh, this is interesting.
Like, hey, I want to do this.
And so when we were in the warehouse, you were just taking your like mental notes, mental notes.
It was just spinning, spinning and spinning.
My head was just spinning.
I was like, oh, my God.
So what happens when they're like, okay, we're going to give you lines?
Because you started off background.
Correct.
So now, do you remember when they're like, we want, we have some words for you.
I remember.
Because, you know, Creed started off as background.
Exactly.
And then all of a sudden they were like, had this huge scene.
Here's a scene.
Yes.
And he was like, oh, okay, I'm speaking now.
And that's what I heard.
And I was like, oh, great for Creed.
I remember the episode.
It's when Michael Scott comes down.
This is when he was talking about having a baby.
And Craig was on the couch and I was sitting on a bench.
And he said something to Greg.
And I was like, I forgot the words that I said.
And when I seen that episode on TV, I was like, yeah, we got to work on some things.
Because at that point in time, I was still in the awe moment.
Yeah.
And you can see it on my face.
And I was just like, oh, my God, I'm speaking?
Really?
And you can see that excitement on my face where it shouldn't have been that?
So I had to work on some things.
But after seeing that, I was like, okay, all right.
Well, you had a great scene in the St. Patrick's Day episode.
Yeah.
So you go up, you're in Daryl's office, right?
Because now basically he has this pitch to Joe Bennett about how to like make the whole process of like delivering paper, like better and more expedited.
And so she's like, fine.
You know what?
You need to be up here in the main office, take Jim's office.
and then there's this great scene
where you and the other warehouse guys,
you're going to go up to Daryl's new office
and you're like, we're going to bust you out of here.
And then you kind of give them shade.
You're like, dude, did you tuck your shirt in?
Yeah.
No, no, no, no.
It's like you have like some real laugh moments in that scene.
Yeah, yeah.
I always have fun working with Craig.
We kind of developed a great friendship on that show.
Mm-hmm.
I mean, I had friends in L.A.,
but I didn't really have a friend like that in L.A.
You know, we hung out outside the show.
And you still hanged.
out together and work together.
Correct.
Can you share a little bit about that with everyone?
Yeah, so after the office, Craig was, I want to say he was about to shoot Mr. Robinson
and they needed a stunt guy for him.
And I didn't have anything going on.
So I approached the stunt coordinator and I told him, I said, hey, if you don't have Craig's
stunt double you.
I said, I'll grow my hair out, grow my beard out.
We're good to go.
He's like, come see me in two months.
when I came and seen him.
He was like, oh, okay, you fit it, let's go.
So then I started taking stun classes and stuff like that, but me and him been rocking ever since.
Yeah, you double for him a lot.
He did that commercial for AT&T where you doubled for him.
You're like covered in all the pillows.
We have to like bust through a door.
Correct.
Yeah, that was you.
So that was fun.
And then we did a whole second round of wake up with Craig and you were on set every day.
You worked all day.
We were with you all day long.
Correct.
I did the driving scene on that one, too, as well.
Yes.
Yeah.
So there's a scene where we all pull up to the new office.
You drive in as Craig.
Yeah.
They were like, yeah, just drive this Mustang like 40 miles an hour down this alley.
And then make a hard right into the parking spot.
Like, right?
And you did it.
And by the way, we're standing there.
We're like, what, two feet from the car?
Yeah.
Like I'm like, Calvin, you got this?
You're like, yeah, I got it.
Got it. Great moments. Great moments.
Well, there's a scene between Glenn and Daryl and also He-Day.
And it's from a free family portrait.
Oh, my God, it's so funny. It's so funny.
It's so good.
I thought I could see you about to break.
I thought, now, I know you didn't, but there's a little twinkle in your eye once you know you.
And wait, can we hear it?
Yes, let's listen to it.
Let me get this straight.
You lost all of it.
all your winnings, $150,000.
But to economy, but to investment.
You mean to tell me no one wanted an energy drink
for Asian homosexuals?
They did not.
And you got half a million of these?
Well, I gotta try it.
I wouldn't.
Come on, it's the hard.
Mmm.
Flavor is that?
Coconut penis.
Coconut is pretty subtle.
They did not.
I wouldn't.
And then also when he's like, the coconut is pretty subtle.
It's like, that was so funny.
But that's such a great storyline that the whole warehouse wins the lottery.
Yes.
And then quits.
And quits.
And like moons everybody.
Like you guys really like come up and like dance around and be like F you everyone.
I have a question for you.
When you guys quit, were you worried?
Were you like, no.
What is this storyline?
Exactly, exactly.
Come on.
I was like, we win the lotto and what happens after that?
I was like, oh, my God, just the end of us?
And me and He day were talking.
I was like, hey, man, we might not come back.
So after we won a lottery, we left.
And I was just watching episodes of the office.
I was just like, oh, my God, are they going to write us back in?
What's going to happen?
So the last episode, my agent calls me and said, hey, they're bringing you back.
I was like, oh, my goodness.
So the last episode of season eight, they brought us back.
And that's where that scene came from.
I was like, thank you.
That scene is so great.
I want you to know, I went down the rabbit hole looking for bloopers.
I was positive that there was a blooper from that scene.
I actually really want to reach out to Dave Rogers and be like, I know you guys look like you're about to lose it.
But if I find that blooper, I'm going to send it to you.
Yeah, he day is so funny.
And we're still friends to this day as well.
So, yeah, He Day is a good friend of mine.
I had such a fun time hanging out with you guys at the office fan convention.
Yes.
And just catching up.
And he is the sweetest.
Yes.
The sweetest guy.
He is.
And I have a question sort of in that vein.
How has being on the office changed your life?
Because you're going to these fan conventions now.
You must get recognized.
Correct.
Funny story.
Before I cut my hair and all of that stuff, I get recognized a lot.
But now my twin brother gets recognized as me on the office because he's, he's, he's, he's,
still looks like that. Yes. So it's amazing. And when he's out and about and he calls me up and he said,
hey, or he'll text me first. Can I FaceTime you? Someone wants to say hi. They thought all was you.
So I want to introduce him to the real you. But he was also on an episode. Yes, the Matrix,
the Matrix. So Jam is pranking Dwight so that Dwight thinks he's in the Matrix. Correct.
And so the glitch in the Matrix where you see the like carbon footprint of yourself and you know there's a
glitch, you know, like how the cat crosses the road twice. It's you and your twin are the glitch
and the matrix. Correct. That's amazing. Well, so when people run into him and ask him fees on
the office, he's like, technically yes, but I think the person you want to talk to is my brother.
Correct. Yeah. It's funny. To me, it's funny and so great at the same time. Yeah. The office is like
one of them shows that most people wish they were a part of. I mean, I didn't know what I was getting
into. I'm pretty sure you ladies didn't either. Oh, no way. So this thing is like, it's still out there
just making new fans. You know, it's pretty wild, right? Correct. Yeah. And the people that love it
know it so well. They will know that your character had three names. Like, they know all those details,
you know? Correct. Correct. I mean, there was a woman at the convention, and she has the Holy Grail tattooed
on her calf. Oh, yeah. That is crazy. That you know. So I was like, that you know,
You dip your donut into your character?
Correct.
Oh, my gosh.
Wow.
She was like, I want to show you something.
So she has Michael Scott tattooed on her arm or something like that.
So she has everyone tattooed on her body.
And I was like, oh, my God.
So the fans are amazing.
They are.
They are a wonderful community.
I'm so thankful for them.
I am so curious.
We ask anyone, you know, that we've had on here that's been on the office,
if they had a favorite scene or episode or just what is your fan moment from being on the office, the episode you love?
Oh, man, it's so many.
I know.
It's hard, right?
We get asked this question all the time.
You know what?
I love all your episodes with Rain, the interaction between you guys.
It's so comical.
And your love story with Jim, it's like, couldn't get any better than that, you know?
Like I said, I was just the person in the back field watching you guys.
work. So every part of that show I love, you know, there's not just one episode that I loved. I loved
at all. I'm like, let's go back and do it again. Not to shoot what we already shot. Let's go back and
do it again. You know what I mean? It would be really cool. You know, we've talked about that.
If we could go back to one episode or one moment and do it again. And I feel like we always say like just a
one big ensemble scene where we're all together.
Yeah.
You know, I was watching weight loss where we're all in the warehouse and we're all standing
on that and like Andy sort of like spits.
Thinks he's going to lose weight by spitting and you give him such a like, oh my God,
terrifying like scary look.
But we were all in this little, you know, room or we'd be in a conference room scene.
Those kind of moments where we were all together was really special moments.
Yes.
It was all special, yes.
Well, before we let you go, is there anything about your time on the office that you haven't shared with us?
Any behind-the-scenes stories or memories?
We spent so much time on that show.
I think every moment that I spent on the show was a great memory for me.
There's not one that stood out because I was just so excited to get there.
Yeah.
You know, whenever I was working just to see you all, you know, and be a part of it.
So, yeah, just being there, every time I had a chance to be there was a great memory for me.
Yeah.
It was great people, great food.
Always great food.
Great comedy.
But also, like, how crazy is it that this thing that we did so long ago, it's still being watched?
It's still beloved.
And, you know, it's endured.
You're part of that.
You know, you're part of this wonderful thing.
I tell some of my family members, I'm like, it's the gift that keeps giving because it's not going anywhere.
It's right there in front of your face.
If you turn on the TV, it's right there.
You don't really have to search that hard for it.
Just go through the channels, the office.
Yeah.
Office.
Oh, my gosh.
Have you been on a plane and watched someone watch the office?
I have.
Yeah.
And a part of me want to say, hey, I was in that.
They totally love it.
I have yet to see someone watch an episode I was on, but I've seen people watch it, you know.
So that's amazing.
And what does your family think?
Are you the first actor in the family, the first person to work in the entertainment industry?
Yes.
So what is that like for that?
My mom thinks it's hilarious.
Okay.
You know, she's like, so what are you working on now?
Like, what are you doing today?
Like, so.
And she knows, like, I'm always on set doing.
something because I'm pretty sure you all already know me.
Well, my wife owns, she owns House of Talent, a commercial casting company, TV and film,
stuff like that.
And we're always on set.
So it's amazing.
You know, I have to say something, all those years we were working together, and we'd be
on the set, and sometimes there'd be really long shoot days, especially for some reason
when we were in the warehouse in particular, I feel like there were really big plot lines or
big stories over there. Well, it was very cavernous. And so they would spend more time figuring out
where to put the cameras sometimes because it was a very big space. Very big space. So we did,
there was a lot of coverage down there. And my memory of you on those long days is just looking
over at you and you would always have the biggest smile on your face. Like zero complaints,
so happy to be here. It's, whenever you feel welcome, you're happy.
So you guys welcome me into a family.
And I was like, oh, man, okay, all right.
So that's all I can do is smile and be happy and appreciate it, you know.
So I appreciate my time on that show and everything I've done after that.
So I appreciate all of it because every day is a great day.
You know, there's no bad days, at least in my book, you know.
Oh, my gosh, Calvin, we need more of you in this world.
I'm telling you right now.
Oh, well, thank you for coming in today.
Come on, Calvin.
You just absolute ray of sunshine of a human.
Thanks so much for being here.
Thank you, ladies, for having me.
It's been a pleasure.
We're still friends.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
Well, thank you so much.
Stay in touch.
We love you.
Love you.
Love you both.
Well, how delightful was that?
Love him.
I know.
He's just good people.
It's like seeing.
like your cousin. You're like, oh my God, how are you? It really is true. It's that office family is forever.
And every time any of us see each other, it's just a joyous occasion. Yeah. All right. Well,
should we get to a little Around the Town lady? Let's do it. Our first Around the Town is from
Alexandra L and Coraville, Iowa. Alexandra said every May, the town holds a citywide garage sale weekend,
followed by a swap weekend where everyone can bring their unwanted stuff to the City Hall parking lot
and take whatever they want for free.
Items not claimed are donated to a nonprofit.
After that comes Mayors Cleanup Week where everyone puts the remaining unwanted items on the curb for trash pickup.
People all over town then drive around and pick out treasures before the trash pickup happens.
It's amazing what you can find in good shape.
We always enjoy searching for treasures three weeks in a row.
We've ended up with a play set, kitty pool, cat tree, patio set, tons of kids' clothes, and so much else from these events.
I've never lived anywhere so dedicated to reusing unwanted items.
How fantastic is that?
The whole town is spring cleaning at the same time.
I love it.
It's so smart.
I love a garage sale.
I love everything about this.
And then the swap and then the things for free.
Come on.
I got very worked up about that one.
Sorry, I was very excited.
It's very cool.
All right, mine is from Margaret C.
and Masselin, Ohio, who said,
our thriving, quote, city of champions
of 32,000 Massalonians is celebrating its 200th birthday this year.
Massalind's history includes providing a safe haven
of the Underground Railroad,
being a historic shipping town on the Ohio and Erie Canal,
and later a hub for steel and heavy industry.
Some of our towns, many noted citizens, include silent film stars Lillian and Dorothy Gish,
Browns and Bengals coach Paul Brown, and actors David Canary, Yvette Nicole Brown, and Matt Lanter,
and singer Jeff Timmons.
Our Masselin Tigers High School football team also has an elite history with 25 state championships.
We are really so proud of our Northeast Ohio City and invite everyone to celebrate at our many patriotic events,
this year. Massland, Ohio is crushing it. Happy birthday. Happy birthday. 25 state wins. What?
Well done. Our next one is from Sam C. in Gainesville, Florida. Sam says, at age 21, I just released
my first album. I make music under the name Sam Cone. So to celebrate, I threw a cone-themed
listening party. My friends and I snacked on pop cone, conola, ice cream cones, chips con queso, and
bugles. Oh, because bugles are in the shape of a cone lady. While we listened to the album titled
Whist Away, drinks included vodka cone berries and pina cone ladas. We had a blast. Oh, Sam,
congratulations. Yeah. At 21? 21, Sam Cone. Way to go. Wow. I don't know what I was doing
at 21, but I hadn't just finished a whole album, I'll tell you that.
I know where I was when I turned 21.
Had you finished something like an album?
I was writing a term paper at my desk, and I didn't go out and celebrate, but I did go to
the gas station.
My dad had given me a gas card just for gas, but I would buy groceries on it.
And I went in proudly, and I bought myself a Coronita, which is a mini bottle of beer.
to celebrate your 21st birthday because you were in the middle of a term paper.
Yes.
But it wasn't an album, Sam Cohn.
It was just a term paper.
Well, let's move on to our office question of the week.
Yeah, this one is coming from Ella M in Louisiana who says,
Hi, Office Ladies.
Do you have a favorite show with a similar vibe as The Office?
What other shows should Office fans watch?
Well, my family just did a rewatch of Modern Family.
which has that same sort of like cutting away to talking heads to like interview segments.
I think the comedy is really good.
I would recommend that.
But you know what they don't do like we do is break the fourth wall.
So there's none of that looking to camera.
It's not documentary style, but it's sort of documentary style.
But I think that's pretty close.
Yeah.
I mean, this is a great question.
I really liked it.
So I was thinking, you know, my family and I are watching.
right now. It's the first time for the kids seeing it, but we're watching Arrested Development.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. And it's got that very single camera. You kind of feel like you're watching,
like getting the people inside some family's life. Yeah. It's very quirky. It's very funny.
And then I was always a fan of Reno 9-1-1. Oh, that's a great answer. Yeah. Because that is very much in the same
style. And I think if I were thinking of like new shows, like shows today, I would say,
jury duty, written by Lee and Gene. For sure. So good. I would say St. Dennis Medical,
and Animal Control. Yeah. And also, you know, the show Superstore, created by Justin Spitzer.
Oh, yes. That similar vibe. It does. It's a good comedy. You know, for me, this idea of a fake
documentary TV show goes back to the Larry Sanders show. I loved that show. So good. And if you haven't seen it,
It's just fantastic.
It's behind the scenes of a talk show.
Yeah, of a late night talk show.
In fact, the DP that shot the office pilot shot the Larry Sanders show.
He was just with us for that one episode, the pilot, Peter Smokler is his name.
But, you know, you're going to see that same kind of style.
But again, they don't break the fourth wall.
And they don't do talking heads.
It's more like caught on the fly documentary sort of thing.
You know what I was thinking about as far as breaking the fourth wall?
the fourth wall in a really, really cool, inventive way was fleabged.
Oh, yes.
Because the scene plays out and then she'll look straight to camera and have this aside.
Not to a documentary crew.
It's like her inner thoughts to herself.
Yes.
And then if I could give a shameless plug.
Oh, yeah, do it.
I have become a recurring character on the Chit Show, which is a group of Groundlings folks,
and it's a digital series, and it's so fun and funny.
and it's in an office and there's all the camera whips and there's breaking the fourth wall.
It's really taking me back.
Like, I love this group of people.
And it's just been my absolute pleasure.
I was so honored that they asked me.
I was so flattered that they asked me.
So I play Bitsy, who is the auditor from corporate, who's come down.
And so every once in a while I show up.
And no one likes, no one.
I'm real tough.
No one's happy to see an auditor, right?
No, no one.
And Bitsy's really grouchy because she has a rash that goes from her knee to her neck.
I love the name Bitsy, by the way.
She's having to deal with this rash all the time, and it just puts her in a, she's in a sour mood a lot.
Yeah.
Go check that out.
It's really fun to see Jenna in this role.
And Angela, you've got a plug before we go.
Oh, gosh.
I don't know.
It's not so much a plug.
It's just like, hey, if you guys are in Raleigh, North Carolina, July 25th through the 26,
Rain Wilson and I are going to be there at GalaxyCon.
And, you know, I love meeting office fans.
I love chatting with people.
So come say hi.
Well, there you have it, folks.
I think this was a fun episode.
Yeah.
We set the record straight on some things.
We got to talk to Calvin.
We learned about this incredible, I kind of want to go next May to Iowa.
I know.
I mean, I'd like to see that.
Lady, you know I want a road trip with you.
I know.
And a road trip to a garage.
with my best friend.
I know.
Get out.
I'm in.
All right, everybody.
Have a great week.
We'll see you next week.
See you then.
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jennifer Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
Our senior producer is Matt Beagle and our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer.
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz.
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton.